بعينيك الخبيرتين، ماذا ترى عندما
تنفجر الطائرة بدون طيار هناك، نعم
هناك، بوريس، ما تنظر إليه
هو ضربة مباشرة، لذا فإن الأسلحة المضادة للطائرات
التي نشرها الكرملين
حولها لأغراض الحماية، كما
تعلم، كانت مشغولة بشكل واضح  ويبدو
أنك تعرف في نظري كما لو أنهم كانوا
يعرفون بالضبط ما كانوا يطلقون النار عليه
ومتى سيصل هذا الهدف
أه إلى منطقتهم، شيء آخر
مثير للاهتمام هناك شخصان على ما
يبدو يتسلقان هذه القبة وأردت أيضًا الإشارة إلى ذلك
هناك
مسرح كبير للجلوس هنا، إنه
توقع ليوم النصر في التاسع من مايو، وهو
يوم رمزي كبير لروسيا، وربما هو
اليوم الذي ربما أرادت فيه أوكرانيا
هدفًا، هذا ممكن لأنه كما
قلت بوريس، فأنت تعلم أن التاسع من مايو هو
عطلة كبيرة حقًا من
المنظور العسكري في روسيا، هذا هو المكان الذي
يُظهرون فيه الكثير من أسلحتهم التي فعلت ذلك
تاريخيًا منذ نهاية
الحرب العالمية الثانية، وترى اللافتات التسعة الخاصة
بشهر مايو
هنا للعلم الروسي في
الرمال، كل هذا يحصل عليه
جاهز لعرض عسكري كبير ولذلك
من منظور رمزي، سيكون من
المنطقي لشخص ما أن يهاجم
شيئًا كهذا ولكنه سيكون أيضًا
مكانًا مثاليًا لشن عملية علم زائف
وهي نقطة جيدة وعندما
نلقي نظرة أخرى على هذا  زاوية جديدة
للطائرة بدون طيار أه تنفجر تراها هنا
في الجزء العلوي الأيسر وهذا المنظر
مهم بسبب السياق بسبب ما
تراه هذا قريب جدًا من
الساحة الحمراء وكاتدرائية القديس باسيل
على الجانب الأيمن ليس بعيدًا عن
كاتدرائية البشارة أيضًا، أنت
تتخيل أن هذه المنطقة يجب أن تكون
محمية بشكل جيد جدًا تمامًا وأنت تعلم إذا
نظرنا إلى الخريطة هنا، يوجد مربع أحمر
هنا، هذا هو المكان الذي سيقام فيه العرض
كاتدرائية البشارة، حيث
تلقى القياصرة الاعتراف حيث  كان هناك
مصلى خاص بهم في زمن
القياصرة، لذا فهو مكان رمزي كبير بالنسبة
لروسيا ومن
الواضح أنهم يريدون حمايته، كما أن كنيسة
القديس باسيليوس بالطبع
مشهورة جدًا كجزء من هيكل الكرملين
نفسه بالنسبة إلى  النقطة التي أشار إليها جيم
حول مدى سذاجة الادعاء الروسي
بأن هذه هي أوكرانيا، دعنا نسحب
الخريطة، هذا على بعد حوالي 300 ميل من
الحدود الأوكرانية، تخيل أن هذه
الطائرة بدون طيار لم تقلع من هنا
في ضوء ما تعرفه عن أوكرانيا
القدرات وقدرات روسيا
لمعرفة ما سيأتي، هل يبدو من المحتمل
أن هذا كان هجومًا أوكرانيًا
غير مرجح لهذا السبب بالذات
لأن الروس لديهم
منشآت رادار على طول هذه المنطقة
هنا والمكان الذي من
المرجح أن يطلقوا فيه شيئًا كهذا
منه  سيكون هنا أه ونظرًا
لهذه الحقيقة، فهو أطول قليلاً
من 300 ميل، سيستغرق الأمر الكثير من
الوقود وسيستغرق وقتًا للتسكع الذي
تمتلكه بعض هذه الطائرات بدون طيار الآن، فمن
الممكن أن تكون أوكرانيا قد شنت
هذه العملية من داخل روسيا باستخدام
قوات العمليات الخاصة ليست
خارج نطاق الاحتمال ولكن من
غير المحتمل على الرغم من أنها
شنت هجمات مزعومة ضد
المناطق في الجنوب ضد القواعد الجوية
وأشياء من هذا القبيل، لذا فهذه مناطق
يمكن استهدافها ولكن من الصعب جدًا
القيام بذلك و  كما قال الرئيس زيلينسكي
إنهم لا يستهدفون القيادة
روسيا هي التي ستستخدم روسيا هذا
كذريعة لفعل شيء كهذا على الأرجح
ولكن من غير المرجح أن يكون
جاء من أوكرانيا